[Musica]
il nostro orizzonte il mondo
la prima cosa che ho pensato che se che
non non c'è vita senza orizzonte
senonchè l'orizzonte vuol dire che
vediamo soltanto il nostro talmente
piccolo la vita stessa è un orizzonte
cerca all'orizzonte ha bisogno
dell'orizzonte e quindi per forza il
nostro orizzonte il mondo siamo fatti
per stare in questo orizzonte grande
sarebbe vero sarebbe completato il
contrario cioè complicato quando
l'orizzonte non è più il mondo però
all'orizzonte si vede partendo da un
punto altrimenti ci si perde e tutti noi
nasciamo viviamo siamo anche in un punto
ma è quel punto che da cui posso capire
e vedere l'orizzonte capire quindi il
mio punto e dell'orizzonte che me lo
spiega altrimenti non lo capisco ma
anche provare a orientarmi in qualcosa
sennò davanti dentro il quale è facile
perdersi perché se non c'è un punto poi
ci si perde l'orizzonte poi è complicato
perché credo che sia esperienza di tutti
quanti noi che a un certo punto
l'orizzonte non si capisce più dove
finisce il male e dove comincia il cielo
dove finisce la terra e dove comincia il
cielo c'è una linea che si confonde
io penso lo credo che per ognuno di noi
guardare orizzonte significa anche
capire quello che ci unisce e che unisce
la terra il cielo e non capiamo
io penso che cosa ci stiamo a fare sulla
terra senza misurarci anche con quella
grandezza di orizzonte che anche il
cielo stesso noi appunto nasciamo in un
luogo a per imparare a stare dappertutto
c'è una
per la paolo sesso che diceva parlava
della la stanza del mondo è un'immagine
molto bella è l'unica stanza perché qual
è il problema nostro che molte volte
crediamo più alle divisioni non sappiamo
più vedere la stanza ed è terribile
perché non capiamo più chi siamo perché
se io penso che il mondo inizia e
finisca la mia piccola stanza non
capisco più la stanza del mondo e quindi
devo imparare a vivere nella stanza del
mondo
papà francesco parla della casa comune è
molto simile come espressione e ci
invita tutti quanti a ricordarci che la
casa è una e non c'e nessuna di riserva
e che tutti quanti siamo chiamati ad
essere cittadini del mondo
un'espressione che andava molto negli
anni 60 in cui quando si erano visti i
frutti terribili dei nazionalismi quella
caricatura quella di formazione per cui
io tutto parte soltanto da quel punto lì
in cui penso di essere tra i miei e chi
sono i miei la grande capacità di enti
di essere tra i miei a parlare estate
con tutti anche perché se non sappiamo
nemmeno stare coi miei che come sappiamo
in genere i litigi da fratelli su quelli
peggiori perché proprio perché uno dice
come nemmeno so stare con i miei infatti
perché non sa stare con gli altri e se
uno impara a essere il cittadino del
mondo
a vivere in questa stanza che il mondo a
curarsi della casa comune
beh io credo che impara anche a state
con i suoi se non è nemmeno capace di
stare con se stesso
credetemi alla fine si impiccia si
imbroglia anche con se stesso allora due
ultime cose la prima è che c'è un'unica
lingua
c'è un'unica lingua anche dopo
secondo alcuni dio parlava latino oppure
ii a cui dio parla sicuramente solo
arabo secondo alcuni di opal soltanto il
mio dialetto e qual è la lingua del
mondo
io credo che anche l'esperienza che
facciamo non c'è quella dei bambini
avete mai visto dei bambini che non
alcuni che nemmeno sanno parlare oppure
che non hanno la lingua comune o eppure
si capiscono imparano a giocare subito
magari linkano anche un po ma poi ne
hanno bisogno e li fanno pace e
ricominciano a giocare imbrogliarsi
impariamo a parlare la lingua dei
bambini che la lingua del cuore che io
penso che sia la lingua di dio perché è
quella lingua che ci viene insegnata
perché dobbiamo imparare a essere
cittadini del mondo dobbiamo imparare a
vivere nella stanza insieme agli altri
dobbiamo imparare a riconoscere l'altro
se no non lo vedo
non me ne accorgo proprio ci passò nel
non mi interessa e non capisco che il
mio prossimo
guardate prossimo vuol dire è più vicino
è il me ne accorgo solo come un eroe di
bene e quello che permette di vedere
altrimenti è tutto indistinto oppure
penso di chiudermi nella piccola stanza
della mia piccola stanza è l'ultima cosa
che voglio dire questa il mondo non va
mica bene la casa comune e ci ha
parecchi problemi
quell unica stanza ci sta e una prima
stanza in cui una parte della stanza in
cui si mangia di tutto di più e ci sta
una grande parte della stanza dove non
c'è niente la mano
c'è una parte la stanza in cui si
buttano via gli anni e ci stanno la
grande parte della stanza dove gli anni
non ci sono perché la vita dura davvero
poco
e allora dobbiamo pensare che questa
stanza unica questa stanza del mondo
bisogna aggiustarla e sia giusta si può
aggiustare anche perché se non sia
giusta si rovina ancora di più
non puoi pensare che io che mettimi
porta della sua stanza nell'angolo show
miu miu per folle non c'è futuro no e
che per aggiustare la stanza del mondo
deve iniziare da me inizia dalla milizia
dal mio sforzo
inizia da quel piccolo che io posso fare
che è piccolo e molto che in realtà
quello che mi permette di essere davvero
universale perché lo faccio io
e qui comincia con la solidarietà con
l'essere parte dell'unica famiglia umana
con saperi conoscere il prossimo con
vincendo l'indifferenza e provando a
parlare la lingua di bambini grazie
perché questo è fare calcoli
[Applauso]